first couple episodes of this new season
so good the roy family bringing the
drama back to us
how is logan going to handle kendall's
press conference how is it looking for
logan he has to think about it and
that's what he's
doing indeed indeed you've got some
great guest stars coming up as well
you've got adrian brody sinai lathan
alexander skarsgard does logan get to uh
rumble with a few of these folks
uh yes both both adrian and alexander
yeah we do we rumble a bit okay so it's
quite interesting um i'm hearing that
there's a big birthday bash this season
is that correct not for you but maybe
for one of your son's
you see when i'm not involved with any
of my children i don't know what's going
on
logan roy himself was there a lot of
pressure building to bring season three
to fans to the critics because you guys
have received so many accolades so much
praise from the emmys from critics what
was it like bringing season three to the
table well i think that we really just
follow its natural course because and
these are the writers the writers just
take the idea and of course the last
season set up so many incredible ideas
and they it's like a baking a huge rich
cake and they get down to it and that's
what they've been doing is he gonna
watch could we make a note in the
minutes that he's watching us i don't
know why but you i didn't feel that long
for me no it didn't
uh it really didn't i mean you know
because of the excitement of what's been
happening with in the world uh and i
think that one by the time we settled
down it was just oh yes we're going to
be doing it in whenever we started i
can't remember we knew about that we
started in november so we knew it was
going to happen
say in august you know so it wasn't it
didn't feel too long but it's always
great they're a great bunch they're a
fantastic bunch of actors and you know i
just feel that every day there's
something new and exciting